Now, a simple way for you to start
with your customer segment hypotheses is rank
each job according to what you believe
is its significance to the customer.
And you get to guess on day 1 is it crucial or trivial?
And take a guess about how frequently it occurs,
and outline what specific context a job gets done.
I call this the day in the life of a customer.
That is, you ultimately ought to be able to go up
to a white board and diagram for me or anybody else
here's what a customer does from the moment they get up
to when they go to work or when they're at school or something else,
and here are the products they use and the car they drive
and what they read, et cetera, and if you really don't have a deep understanding
of that customer and where your product fits
you're really going to have a hard time understanding them.
Now, just remember on day 1 all you're mostly doing
is guessing, but the whole objective
of getting out of the building is trying to fill in
this day in the life, so actually when you say something
about here's how we ought to go advertise to them or reach them
or get Google AdWords to them that you're just not saying
it's because I think so.
It's because you're saying I've spoken to a ton of these people,
and they'd love to buy our stuff, but here's how we reach them,
or here's the key message we need to deliver.